representative democracy is one of the
cornerstones of the u.s but the process
of bringing people to serve in politics
is not exactly straightforward some
people enter through family business
connections or other avenues of public
service but in an increasingly diverse
nation
how can we get more elected officials
that reflect the makeup of our country
so joining us now with tips on how
underrepresented communities can get
into elected politics is elaine chao she
is a former u.s labor secretary under
president george w bush and former
two-time transportation secretary under
presidents bush senior and president
trump secretary chao welcome to quick
take so good to see you in person thanks
for having me so you've never run for
elected office but you know firsthand
what's involved because you're married
to senator mitch mcconnell who needs to
run for election every six years and
you've observed plenty and a lot of
people come to you for tips so you've
kind of distilled everything into three
points and your first
recommendation or suggestion for people
who want to run for office if they're
underrepresented minority is
pick the right district what do you mean
by that you really have to pick the
right district because you know the
majority of districts
or even states sometimes in the united
states the seat itself
there's a track record there are voter
results from previous elections that
will tell you which way
this particular district or seat will
lean
so many times it's pretty clear that the
seat will be very much red
or it will be very much blue
and if you if you don't really fall if
your philosophy doesn't fall within that
camp it's very difficult for you to win
so find the district that suits your own
particular philosophy that will enable
you to succeed okay i hear what you're
saying but sometimes
people get approached to run for office
and they're like i think you would be a
great candidate for the republican
ticket or the democrat ticket and you're
talking about a seat that is in the
opposite district what's going on there
well of course it's very enticing and
very appealing to have someone come to
you and you know
ask you to run and say you know you're
really needed for the country and we
need you to do this
but i think it's really important to do
your own homework to understand you know
again what is the voter's proclivity and
their leanings in that seat in that
district because many times
the people who are involved in these
campaigns they want a body
someone to occupy that ballot space
because if for whatever reason the wind
is at your back and uh
the whole slate of tick you know of
ballots get elected they want to make
sure that every single spot on their
ballot is filled with somebody so that
when lightning strikes if it does
there'll be somebody who will be swept
into office that is their team but
realistically it's unlikely that you
would if it's um a district in the other
party so you're just being used in a way
well that's why you have to be careful
do your homework okay do your homework
the second one and i think anyone who's
in elected politics can understand this
is you have to raise money that can be a
difficult ask especially if you've never
really done it before oh it's really
easy
it's
it must be easy and that's what if
you're going to run for politics it must
be easy well you know i i've always uh
because
your ability
to separate a voter
from their hard-earned resource is an
indication of their passion for you your
campaign your ideas so that is the first
hurdle to selling yourself selling your
philosophy selling your ideas because
once they give even that one dollar
they're bound to you and they're going
to watch you with greater interest and
they're going to follow you and most
likely they will vote for you how do you
ask for money without actually coming
out to say can you give me money you
must do that you ask them i need a
thousand dollars from you i need a
hundred dollars from you and will you
please help me
you put it as simple as that you've
you've got to put it on your business or
anything oh no no not at all there's no
need to hey listen the donor is busy
also okay so let's just be really
efficient they know why you're there
they know that
having financial resources is really
useful and helpful and necessary for
getting your message out so the fact
that they are talking to you already is
an indication they are interested they
want to help and they are very likely to
be won over so you basically have to
close the deal make a pitch for yourself
and then must must must you must close
the deal which is
this is going to be a campaign in which
i'm going to need your help will you
step up and give me a hundred dollars
and how much of your time don't ask for
anything small okay okay so that's think
big in other words so i was head of
united way yeah and i helped to do a lot
of fundraising for united way
and the worst thing that can happen is
that you ask a person for less than what
they were willing to give initially
although unspoken so you need to go
go big they can always come down but if
you
go small and they were ready to give
something big you can't go back again to
the larger number right right right okay
that's that's a really good take okay so
you have to do your research you have to
know how much they're willing to part
with and you have to just be bold and
ask for the money and close the deal
okay the third tip you have is you have
to have support of the party and by
party you mean either the democrat party
or the republican party it doesn't you
don't really need it and we have seen
candidates who have done very well
without the party's establishment
support but if for instance
oh i think uh you know you have um
a lot of the tea party people who came
in 2010
uh they did not have a lot of party
support initially and they started their
own movement of volunteers and
supporters and on the left and on the
other side you have some of the new the
squad for example
they were just newcomers to the
political scene and yet they were able
to garner enough support and enthusiasm
to be able to you know
spark a movement literally but if you
don't have that so if you don't have the
or
you know you don't
or unless you may not have the movement
you can appeal to the party that's where
the party is helpful because they will
have built-in infrastructure like
volunteers and people who have had
previous experience
volunteering helping out on past
campaigns so their wisdom their
experience is helpful so you can have
that again that whole army of volunteers
and sometimes if you need legal help in
this contest of the results you know the
party can help you with that as well so
there's a lot of just uh practical
assistance
that the party with this infrastructure
can offer so you use the machine to help
you move forward
are you saying don't ever run as an
independent as a third-party candidate
i think it's hard to run as a
third-party candidate because again both
parties democrat and republican have the
infrastructure
foremost being for example volunteers
they will turn out because you are the
republican candidate or you are the
democrat candidate but if you're
independent it's not to say that that is
impossible but it's harder to build up
the infrastructure what if you have the
name recognition already for instance
i'm thinking andrew yang he ran for
president as a democrat as one of many
democrats he ran for mayor of new york
city in the primary as one of many
democrats and now he's formed his own
party called the ford party
well i wish him luck andrew yang will be
forever a figure of history for what he
has done he's the first asian-american
candidate to run for president and for
that he will always have a place in
history so i'm glad you mentioned first
asian american because you are the first
api woman to serve in the president's
cabinet
did you see the recent snl skit where um
the guest host simulu and the cast
member bon yang who's the first asian
american cast member were poking fun at
their first asian titles they're kind of
competing each other one-upping each
other on representational wins i mean
he was really cute i actually used to
watch simul i watched every episode of
lee's convenience kim's convenience
you're a semu fan absolutely and i'm so
delighted that he gets to be a marvel
hero i think it's really important for
our country for our society and actually
for the world as well i'm really proud
of him how does it feel for you to
always have the first asian american
fill in the blank following your name
when i was younger you know it was it
was tough
but because i thought that everything i
did was reflective of our community it
was probably too heavy a burden for me
to take that i didn't have to
necessarily take on but that's how i
felt and so
i wanted everything that i did to
reflect well on the community because i
didn't want
me to be a barrier to future advancement
of other asian americans and i'm glad
that i was able to blaze the trail and
you know provide more open up the doors
more for more opportunities for our
community yeah that must have been
like you said a lot of pressure
um one way or another and but it was
also self-imposed you know i'm asian
american as you well know we put a lot
of pressure on ourselves yeah we do do
that let's talk about asian americans as
a voting bloc because
in the last couple of elections people
have noticed that this is a critical
population a critical community maybe
even a swing vote what's your take on
that how things have evolved
decades
asian americans are they can be a swing
vote they are increasingly becoming a
swing vote in certain key states
asian americans are located primarily in
urban areas and
in blue states so that's like washington
uh california
new york new jersey illinois
massachusetts
they're going into florida which is no
longer a um a blue state and texas
and asian americans are also now
increasingly visible in arizona nevada
north carolina georgia
so they are branching you know moving
out in from these white from these blue
states and they are increasingly a swing
uh vote and i think there uh there's
this trend has been spurred obviously uh
by what's happened uh with the
anti-asian violence and harassment
during covet
did you see the election where michelle
wu won uh the mayor's race in boston
there are actually two women of color
yes in that race in a city like boston
which i think caught a lot of people by
surprise
there was a lot of incorrect press a lot
of incorrect uh claims made before she
won the election um welcome to the club
yeah but i mean people would equate her
with someone who is from china when in
fact she's not her parents immigrated
from taiwan
well running for office is tough
that's part of the game
i hate to call it a game and i don't
want to it's not a game but you know the
stakes are so high
and the ultra partisanship which our
country now is experiencing contributes
to that kind of vitriol
and i've been attacked
um
and i think uh and what i'm concerned
most is if someone like me
who
you know can be attacked and
what does that mean for people who
may not be as visible
so i'm concerned about
what these i'm concerned about i mean
this whole
issue and i've been helping
many other asian american groups
and
organizations to establish themselves to
come up to provide more voices for our
community and i was among the very first
to come out against asian american
violence
around march 18th in atlanta when that
happened
so i think
our consciousness as a group as a
community is being raised and i hope
that there will be more candidates and i
hope that the tips that i've given will
be helpful i think it'll be good for our
country
elaine chao thank you so much thank you
elaine chao's former labor labor
secretary and former transportation
secretaries as well